VIOLENT RHETORIC AND READY TO
PLAY THIS TAPE IN HIS PLAY VERY
ENTERTAINING.
THE FIRST EVIDENCE IS UNDENIABLE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
FAILED DUE TO THE PEOPLE ONCE
AGAIN.
IN THE BORDER IS WIDE OPEN.
ANY ATTEMPTS AT DIPLOMACY WITH
MEXICO OR OTHER COUNTRIES, IN
CENTRAL AMERICA OR SOUTH AMERICA
THEY HAVE ALL FAILED.
THAT MEANS THAT NOW, OPEN
FIELDS, THEY KEEP MUDDLING
ACROSS THE BORDER AND IT KEEPS
HAPPENING.
AND NOW THE NUMBER ONE KILLER OF
YOUNG AMERICANS IN OUR COUNTRY,
AND THIS BODY CAN VIDEO IT
REPORTEDLY SHOWS A POLICE
OFFICER OVERDOSING AFTER
ACCIDENTALLY INHALING THAT NOW
DURING A TRAFFIC STOP.
MEANWHILE, DANGEROUS MEXICAN
CARTELS ARE MORE POWERFUL THAN
EVER AND MORE WEALTHY THAN EVER
BEFORE, THEY HAVE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, SEX TRAFFICKING,
CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
THAT TOO IS AT AN ALL-TIME HIGH.
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS THEY ARE
OVERWHELMED.
AND BORDER TOWNS ARE OVERRUN
WITH MIGRANTS, FACILITIES ARE AT
CAPACITY, AND AFTER TWO YEARS OF
RECORD HIGH ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
IT IS NOW AND SEVEN DAYS ARE
ABOUT TO GET WAY WORSE THAN EVER
BEFORE.
BECAUSE, NOW WE HAVE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THEY ARE NOW
UNMASKING IN NORTHERN MEXICO.
JUST ACROSS THE BORDER WHILE
THEY ARE PREPARING TO CROSS NEXT
WEEK.
IN SEVEN DAYS WITH TITLE 42
CONCERNING.
NOW IT'S OUT THIS TRUCK ERA
POLICY IN PLACE, VIRTUALLY
NOBODY WHO CROSSES THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY WILL BE DEPORTED AFTER
TWO LONG YEARS.
THE SITUATION IS SO DIRE THAT
EVEN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA MOB
THERE STARTED TO TAKE NOTE TAKE
A LOOK.
>> WHICH IS GROWN NOW TO THE
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS IN THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
A NEW WAVE OF MIGRANTS AS
FLOODING ACROSS THE BORDER.
>> THEY'RE ASKING FOR MORE
FEDERAL MONEY AFTER MORE THAN
2400 MIGRANTS CROSSED THE BORDER
OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> THE BORDER PATROL AND ARE
PASSED OR NOT REPORTING AN
AVERAGE OF 2400 ILLEGAL BORDER
CROSSINGS EVERY DAY.
WITH THE SURGE OF MIGRANTS MAYBE
FROM CENTRAL AND SOUTH AMERICA
OVERWHELMING BORDER OFFICIALS.
>> MARKET FACILITIES AND
CAPACITY HERE, FORCING THEM TO
TRANSFER TO OTHER PARTS OF THE
BORDER.
OF CALLING THE SITUATION AND
ABSOLUTENESS.
>> I'VE BEEN THAT HIS EXACT
SPOT FOR YEARS ON MIGRATION, AND
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING QUITE
LIKE THIS.
>> Sean Hannity: THE QUESTION
I HAVE, IS WHERE THESE PEOPLE
BEEN FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS?
CERTAINLY NOT AT THE BORDER AND
NOTICE HOW THEY'RE TREATING THIS
LIKE SOME KIND OF NATURAL NEW
PHENOMENON WITHOUT A KNOWN CAUSE
OR CURE.
AND JUST LIKE WANT TO THE
PRESIDENT GOT NEWSOM IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS ALL ABOUT
MEASURING THE DRAPES IN THE
OVAL OFFICE, HE IS REALLY TRYING
HE SAYS TO FIGURE OUT WHY THE
BORDER IS SUCH A MESS.
AND IT IS PART OF HIS ONGOING
PRESIDENTIAL BID, AND NEWSOME
ACTUALLY TOOK TIME ON THAT DON'T
BUY THAT HE DID VISIT THE BORDER
ON MONDAY, AND DECLARED THAT
AMERICANS IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IS
ABOUT THE COLLAPSE TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE FACT IS, BUT WE'VE GOT
RIGHT NOW IS NOT WORKING AND IT
IS ABOUT TO BREAK IN A POST-42
WORLD.
UNLESS YOU TAKE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY AND OWNERSHIP.
AND I'M SAYING THAT AS A
DEMOCRAT, I'M NOT SAYING THAT
THE POINT FINGERS BUT I'M SAYING
THAT AS A FATHER, AS SOMEONE
THAT FEELS RESPONSIBLE FOR BEING
PART OF THE SOLUTION AND I'M
TRYING TO DO MY BEST HERE.
>> OKAY REALLY GAVIN, YOU GOT
TO BE KIDDING US.
YOU OWN THIS, THE DEMOCRATS YOU
ALL ON THIS.
YOU OPEN THE BORDER AND YOU
HALTED WALL CONSTRUCTION.
THAT WAS WORKING, YOU ENDED HIS
STAY IN MEXICO POLICY, AND THEY
TOLD THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THAT
YOU WERE THE ONE SAYING COME ON
HAND, COME ONE COME WALL.
AFTER ALL CALIFORNIA IS A GREAT
CENTURY STATE.
IN FACT BY THE WAY, IF YOU LOOK
AT THE TIME LINE, 72019 DURING
HIS INAUGURAL ADDRESS,
GAVIN NEWSOM HIMSELF BOUND FOR
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE A SANCTUARY
FOR ALL WHO SEEK IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TOGETHER LET US BUILD A
HOUSE STRONGER THAN THE COMING
STORMS.
GET OPEN TO THE WORLD.
A HOUSE THAT PROVIDE SHELTER TO
ALL WHO NEED IT, AND SANCTUARY
TO ALL WHO SEEK IT.
>> AND FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A
HUNDRED AND 75 YEARS, PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING CALIFORNIA IN GREATER
NUMBERS AND ACTUALLY GOING IN.
AND THAT INCLUDES THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THAT HE IS LETTING
IT.
NOW THEY DIDN'T LIST THAT THEY
ARE ALL COMING AND THEY'RE ALL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, BUT BY THE
WAY NOT ONLY DID HE INVITE THEM,
THEY ALSO SUPPORTED POLICIES
THAT PAY FOR THE HOUSING.
IN THE HEALTH CARE.
IN CALIFORNIA EVEN HAS AN ENTIRE
DEPARTMENT DEDICATED TO HANDING
OUT TAXPAYER CASH TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
AND DON'T FORGET ALSO NEWSOM
ALSO SIGNED A BILL THAT ALLOWS
ILLEGALS TO GET STATE IDs.
WE ALSO SUPPORTED SP 54, AND
THAT THE PREVENTED STATE AND
LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT FROM
WORKING WITH ICE TO SUPPORT
CRIMINAL ILLEGAL ALIENS.
AND IN 2018 HE TWEETED THAT
SANCTUARY POLICIES SAID IS TO
KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES SAFE.
BUT IS NOT TRUE.
IN 2019 HE ACCUSED
PRESIDENT TRUMP OF MAKING THINGS
WORSE ON IMMIGRATION, AND HE
TWEETED SAYING THAT HE WILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE STRUCTURE TO
ALL WHO NEED IT AND SANCTUARY
LAWS SEEK IT.
CALIFORNIA WAS FOR EVERYONE.
MY SUGGESTION, IF YOU'RE IN
AMERICA ILLEGALLY, GO OUT TO
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE GAVIN IS
PROMISING TO TAKE CARE OF YOU.
NOT EVERYONE BY THE WAY
INCLUDING CRIMINALS APPARENTLY
EVERY SINGLE MONTH, NOBODY IS
KILLED, BY AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
HIS SHOTS AND CRIMINALS FROM ICE
DOES NOT MAKE THIS COUNTRY
SAFER.
OPEN BORDERS WITH UNFETTERED
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION DOES NOT
MAKE YOU MORE SECURE.
AND I SUPPORT LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
AND BY THE LID THAT WOULD
INCLUDE BETTING PEOPLE SO THAT
WE CAN FIND OUT IF THEY HAVE
RADICAL ASSOCIATION.
AND CONTROLS AS IT RELATES
IMMIGRATION BUT THIS
FREE-FOR-ALL, NO THAT IS
WORKING.
NOBODY IS THAT IT, NO WAS
DEPORTED, INTERNATIONAL
NIGHTMARE.
SO PLEASE SPARE US THE FULL
OUTRAGE GAVIN NEWSOM AND TRY THE
UNINSURED CHANGE.
BY THE WAY, HE DID THIS,
JOE BIDEN VEGAS, KAMALA HARRIS
DID THIS, AND IF NEWSOM REALLY
WANTED TO FIX A BROKEN SYSTEM,
HE WOULD REPEAL HIS OWN STATE
SANCTUARY LAWS, AND WORK WITH
ICE TO DEPORT CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS RIGHT AWAY.
HE'S NOT DOING THAT, THAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
FIXING THE BOARD AND SAVING
LIVES HE JUST WANTS TO BE
PRESIDENT.
NOW IT IS PRETTY SIC